we didn't win like you when you're not
necessarily aware of like that I'm
watching you have like this way of
walking that is just so like I'm here
she talks about the way they said what
do I do that turns you on that I'm not
aware of what does this coin oh you
gonna live through this one we're gonna
watch these like I'm walking in on two
people naked with each other yeah I
don't like that it feels like a skin
deep describe the moment II knew I loved
you revenge now you got your phone when
do you feel people judge us and why do
you think they do I felt like I was
looking for a moments like this a lot
more in the beginning of us I was
heavily aware of the fact that you're a
white man black white well I know right
[Laughter]
and I would be like walking around on
like around and every now and then I
wasn't every now and that it was a lot
actually I would like catch people like
I'm looking at me and sometimes it was
just like I'm just like they just
haven't look in that direction but a lot
of the times - it was like a ooh
and I and there's like a question in
their eyes and I I'm I'm always
wondering like what is the question like
do they think that I hate myself they
think that like I don't look like that I
oh geez
so you thinking maybe mainly about
people then which is anything do you
hate I mean I would well that guy when I
got looks from other black people right
that's what I would wonder if that's
what they were thinking of me like does
she not love herself does she not love
like our people right like whenever the
people would stand I'm like even when we
went to breakfast on Saturday he was
there yet looks everywhere white people
I don't got with my cross I mean on
public is there anything you want the
viewers to understand maybe about your
experience cuz you're in a relation with
a white woman so yeah tell us what are
your thoughts it was harder before when
we started switching your comments I
remembers one day she was working at a
store hardware store mm-hmm
she works there and she's at the cashier
and I'm there waiting for an official
[ __ ] stop in front of the cat shirt and
there's a lady that comes to her tail
and she's like yeah there's a very
suspicious man in front that's okay no
he's not he's been there for a while I
know it's okay that's my boyfriend and
the lady said
really I didn't think you were like that
you know you just assumed it was ism but
maybe she thought your girl wasn't
letting you know you know when you talk
about dog whistling and you just know
she knew I'm just saying you know she
could have think it was an insult maybe
it was a real nice compliment that's all
[Music]
no there's that we're getting looks I
get comments a lot when we go like to
New York and stuff like that
man you know you know how to stay stable
it's all happen New York to us walking
down the street I see the looks I feel
it looks that women don't like you at
all
hmm I don't I hear things let me ask you
a question
Oh do you think that you're projecting
some of those negative ideas because the
fact that you have heard some negative
comments so you assume that most people
were standing or staring for negative
reasons reason being when I'm walking
through this street I stare at people
all the time yeah and a lot of people
could see that as me trying to see that
as me being like what's up Green
confrontation yeah so my question is is
some of it
self-imposed I would have been like oh
yes because I'm gonna win a white shake
that I get those comments if I didn't
get the comments that cause go to the
look hmm like look and then when they
pass us I hear them talk mmm it's like
I'm right here I hear you so it's not so
much the fact that I'm like oh yeah
they're looking at me because of that
and I automatically assume hmm some of
the lives that will receive I don't know
maybe they're just looking at me maybe I
look like someone that the only dude I
remind them of they baby dad or
something like that or they cousin that
this I don't know maybe I reminded
myself but I am basing myself off the
looks I get and then the comment that I
hear afterwards so I hear them sometimes
maybe because I'm talking with my girl
in French they assume but I don't
understand English because we'd be
talking in Cuba cocky because the only
thing for foreign yeah yeah
okay so then my second question to you
earlier you said it got easier
time is it easier because you are more
comfortable in your relationship and
much more secure or is it easier because
the world has become more accepting of
interracial I became easier because I
don't give up it's a bit a lot of it's
not just one answer but like by a girl
hmm because you're still empathetic do
you care if she's bothered by the
comments probably I was more bothered by
the comment than she was I would
understand more two comments and
Sheila's something you know just so
that's interesting I'm the one I
actually was aren't more than her
Emily's opposite nobody's the white girl
who wants to be accepted by the
community so much that she gets hurt
when it feels like they're not being
most like I'm never gonna be accepted
she's like I'm not gonna bother about
people that are not part of my life
if my family accept her then she's cool
yeah she's not trying to emulate the
community or try to be like I'm part of
the community I'm gonna be no I mean I'm
doing me if the family accepts me that's
that she understands what challenges
that we have you talk a lot about that
we talked about how we're gonna raise
our kids the thing and I'll talk about
her about to talk like a lot of times I
get pulled over by the cops she was
there with me
mmm you know I mean so me telling her
that she's like yeah I know I was there
they're talking to me like I'm hostage
or something like that
so all that she understands but she's
not trying to please to like better
itself back well just to please they'd
be like she's not gonna bother about
someone that she doesn't even know where
as me because I'm closer to that
community because I represent I'm more
affected than she is what's led to you
not caring about those comments man at
some point you can't stress over some
things you can't change you know I mean
like I gotta choose my battles and not
every reactions needs an action not
every action needs a reaction how many
uh ringers do you have on your things to
say all that to say you can't to [ __ ]
yourself I to say myself to show myself
right now
Koby all that to say there's a lot of
different answers it's not so much that
it got easier there's a little bit of
that he has people getting more or more
accepting but there's also the fact that
there's always going to be a comment as
I'm happy in the community yeah because
they know there's no pictures of my
girls out there and then people like
he's looked like a hot would but again
they're doing the same thing with their
projected their insecurities they've
seen a lot of black men say oh I
wouldn't date oh so because that fact
they assumed the negative of all black
dudes yeah and they start projecting
they assume that I wouldn't date
completely the opposite and it's not
even that it's like I don't date white
woman the woman I'm with happens to be
white that's just different
I didn't choose her because of a skin
color that's not that no no no no that's
not what happened but people assume that
they assume that that's what it is they
assume that it plays a big part in every
relationship
yeah it doesn't really to be honest with
you now it's not hot choose who who gets
judge more you or them I get more
comments and she goes okay why cuz I'm
we're out there mm-hmm
so I would only base it on the fact that
I'm more out there than she is
I'm in the public eye I said mostly men
are women who make comments I mean man
don't care women and I understand why
when they see a black man going out with
a white woman they take it personally
because it has been at some point we
can't deny the fact that that was one of
the reason why I don't even like get mad
get mad and I just keep it moving you
know what I mean cuz I understand what a
hurt is from I'm not like that
they don't know me they assume is really
because they're hurt so I get it I've
heard black man say I'm never gonna do
I've also heard that from them sure and
I'm like oh dude you you know what I
mean so I've heard that and I understand
and that's why I don't get mad if
they're ready to have a conversation we
can have a conversation but if it's a
proper time of course but I'm not even
gonna argue I'm like I think what you
think it's not what it is but it's okay
and I just keep it moving and I go
somewhere else you know
that's pretty much it I think the main
thing is like they whoever you want to
date just you don't have to speak badly
about any group of people whether it's
white women or black women you have to
speak badly about them when you date up
I need the main thing it's for me my
only advice is hide when you wouldn't
want them then pretty much want to avoid
all that stuff
take the white lady into the shadows you
know what I love I love the black dudes
who go to black events with a white girl
and leave me mad bold about it - you're
not I'm up
yeah I mean legs open leaning back hand
on her lap to let everybody know what's
what's she gonna do contest like you
doing the most they're doing there's
some people that do the most it's okay
that's interesting what I had this
epiphany because we went to a black
event which was the galaxy nest yeah and
I had this epiphany and I was like would
I feel comfortable going to this event
with a white Lee and just the fact that
I asked myself that question I'm gonna
thinking like mmm there's something
there
mm-hmm I would my life it would be whack
not to feel comfortable like you know
what I mean like it's but I get it like
all the insults that I've received you
know I'm good
life must be good on the trader side
okay Judas hopefully your Last Supper is
coming soon is coming soon this qur'anic
away biblical the good news bang bang
Tom Cruise okay okay we bring him down
all that rings crazy chanting this is
impossible
[Music]